day three of the derrick chauvin trial
saw yet another eyewitness take the
stand
another view of george floyd's death and
another for whom the emotion of reliving
that day
became at times too much to bear
proving that some of the most powerful
moments in the trial
can be when nothing is said
61 year old charles mcmillan can be
heard here
urging floyd to do what the police say
but the restrained floyd can't move at
one point he can be heard calling for
his mother
get up did your concerns
increase over time
the longer it went on yes ma'am
when the paramedics arrived for mr floyd
i knew then in my mind
and my instinct it was all for mr floyd
he was dead
earlier prosecutors focused on the
events leading up to that confrontation
trying to add context to the moments
before he was pinned to the ground
store clerk christopher martin testified
that floyd
had handed him what he suspected was a
counterfeit twenty dollar bill
which eventually led to the police being
called
later when martin went outside and saw
floyd pinned to the ground
under chauvin's knee he was distraught
if i would have just not taken the bill
this could have been avoided in
cross-examination
the defense focused on floyd's state of
mind while he was in the store
based on your observations of his
behavior his speech patterns
that's what what caused you to form the
impression he was under the influence
correct step out face away and jurors
ended the day seeing floyd's arrest
again and again as one by one the
footage from each of the officer's body
camera
was played in the courtroom this trial
has shown
that so many people who were witnesses
to floyd's death
are still suffering from trauma now
trying to relive it and it's even
affecting the jury
at one point on wednesday the trial had
to be briefly halted
when one female juror while listening to
testimony
suffered from what the judge called a
stress-related reaction
gabriel lozando al jazeera minneapolis